we've done a bunch of examples looking
at the actual molecular structure and
trying to come up with the name in this
video we'll go the other way around
we'll start with a name and see if we
can actually draw the molecular
structure of whatever this might be so
let's start so when you first look at
these it's very daunting but you always
want to start really at the end so you
know what kind of the core of the
structure is going to be so if you look
at the end of this you have an aim so
there's not going to be any double or
triple bonds it's all single bonds it's
a hexadecimal
it's a hexa decane so let's think about
that hexa
deck so hexadeck that's 6 and 10.
hexadeck was a prefix for 16. so this is
16
single bonded single bonded
bonded carbons
carbons and
cyclohexadexane
cyclocyclohexadecane
so 16 single body carbons in
a
ring so this part of it right here so
let me just do so the cyclo hexadeca and
let's draw that part first
it's not easy to draw even a
a
16
carbon ring so let's start here so it's
and then
16. i think i got it let me count them
again and then i can connect them up in
a cycle so it's 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16. all right i drew the
cyclohexadecane
part
now
if we go back a little see we have a 2 9
diisopropyl so what is a what does this
mean this means that we have an
isopropyl at the two and the nine spot
now when you are drawing the structure
from the name you could just arbitrarily
on the someway saw this ring pick what
your one through your 16 spots are so
i'll just arbitrarily pick them one
because i could have drawn this ring any
which way 1 2
3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10
11
12
13 14
15
16. all right so this is this next piece
right here let me do this in magenta 2 9
diisopropyl this is telling us that at
spots number 2
and at spot number nine
i have isopropyls the dyes are saying i
have two isopropyls at two and nine so
you can kind of ignore the dye so i have
an isopropyl and you may or may not
remember that an isopropyl looks like
this it's three carbons so it's going to
be one two
three
and the connection point to the main
ring in this case is going to be in the
middle carbon so it kind of forms a y
all of the isos the isopropyl isobutyl
they all look like y's so this is so
it's going to be linked right over here
it's going to be linked right over there
and that's also going to happen at the
ninth carbon so the ninth carbon we're
going to have another isopropyl
we're going to have another isopropyl at
the ninth carbon all right we've taken
care of the two nine isopropyl then we
have the six ethyl
six
ethyl which is just a two carbon
remember meth is one f is two probe is
three so this is let me write this down
so this is so this is going to be so
probe
is equal to three
isopropyl is equal to that type of shape
right over there
in this case f
f
is equal to two so it's a six ethyl
group so at six we have an ethyl group
so one
two carbons and it's connected at the
six carbon on the six carbon on the main
ring and then finally we have a
cyclopentyl
cyclopentyl so if we look at let me find
a color i haven't used yet let's see
i've already used what this here
cyclopentyl so pent
pent is five but it's five in a cycle so
there's a five carbon ring that's
branching off of the main ring and it's
at the first it's at the first spot so
let me draw five carbon rings so pent
is equal to five so it would look like
this
one two three
four five looks just like a pentagon
that's a cyclopentyl group and it's
attached to the one carbon on my
cyclohexadecane
so it is attached just like that and
we're done we've drawn one cyclopentyl 6
ethyl29 diisopropyl cyclohexadecane
let's do another one
i think we're getting the hang of it
so here
here maybe we could do this one a little
bit faster let's see we have a
tetramethyldodecane so the main root
here is the do decane
doe for two deck for 10 this is a 12
carbon chain it's not in a cycle so let
me just draw it out
so we have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12.
and so we can just number them
arbitrarily just because i could have
drawn this any which way so it's 1 2
3 4 5 6
7
8
9
10
11 12 that's the dodecane all single
bonds and then we have a 3699
tetramethyl and all this is telling us
all this remember meth is one carbon so
all this is telling us is that the three
the six the nine so the three
the six
and twice at the nine spot we have
methyl groups and we have four methyl
groups that's all the tetramethyl is
saying so it's a little bit redundant we
know we have four from here six three
six nine nine we have methyl groups at
each of those places
so we have one methyl group at three and
then that just
that is bonded with the third carbon on
the dodecane chain we have one at six
bonded to the sixth carbon on the
dodecane chain and then we have two at
nine
so we have one that's one at nine and
then we have another one at nine bonded
to the nine carbon on the dodecane chain
and we're done that's it that's three
six nine nine tetra methyl dodecane
let's do another one
one three
bis one one dimethyl ethyl
cyclopentane
so once again just take kind of you know
breathe slowly it's it it's very
daunting right when you look at it but
just start with kind of the core
cyclopentane that's just a simple five
carbon ring
five carbon ring looks like a pentagon
one two three let me try a little bit
better
three
four
five let me draw that
five there you go
that is a five carbon ring and we can
number it however we want so one two
three
four and five and this is telling us
that the one and the three position
at the one and the three position so the
one and three position
we have and the bis is kind of redundant
this is saying we have two of these
things obviously we have two we have one
at the one one at the three so you can
kind of ignore the bis that's just the
convention and we've seen that multiple
times but at each of those positions we
have a 1 1 dimethyl ethyl so what's a
dimethyl ethyl look like so let's think
about it a little bit let's think about
it let me do it in orange so this is
going this is they obviously named it
using systematic naming
and what we have here we have an ethyl
is kind of the core of this side chain
so for an ethyl
ethyl is equal to two carbons so this is
two carbons right there so let me draw a
two carbon
one
two that is two carbons right over there
i'm just drawing it at the three spot
i'll draw it also the one spot actually
so that is two carbons right there
that's the ethyl part and then on one
one so if we number them we number where
it's connected so it's one two
one
two this is saying one one dimethyl so
on this ethyl chain you have two
methyls remember methyl is equal to one
so this is one car you have one carbon
that's what methyl is but you have you
have two of them you have dimethyl you
have it twice at the one spot so you
have one methyl here and then you have
another methyl there same thing over
here you have one methyl on the one spot
and then you have another one methyl on
the one spot and then you are connected
at
positions one and positions three so
you're connected there and you are
connected right over there and you're
done that's it that is our structure now
if you did this with common naming
instead of this being instead of this
being this group being a 1 1 dimethyl
ethyl you might see that okay we're
connected to a group that has one two
three four carbons in it the carbon that
we connected to branches off to three
other carbons it is a tert butyl so you
could also call this a you could also
call this a 1 3. let me just write it
down so another name for this would be
1 3
1 3
tert or sometimes people just write a t
there t
butyl
t butyl
cyclo
actually has to say di ditbutyl because
we have two of them
one three di
t
butyl
cyclopentane
cyclopentane so that would be the common
name